Months before the US Presidential election,
amidst the coronavirus pandemic, famous rapper
Kanye West says he’s running for President.
In an interview, he talked about the coronavirus,
and said “It’s all about God.
We need to stop doing things that make God
mad”.
Some religious and political leaders say the
virus is a punishment from God.
A politician in Pennsylvania described the
virus as “a punishment inflicted upon us”
for our “sins”, and proposed a statewide
day of atonement.
Some Christian evangelicals say the virus
is God’s punishment for abortion and gay
marriage.
An Israeli rabbi said the virus is punishment
for gay pride, and some Islamic preachers
say the virus is punishment from Allah.
[Eminent luminaries] Kourtney Kardashian and
Hulk Hogan both posted a Bible verse to Instagram,
suggesting that the virus is God's wrath.
So how popular is this idea?
A 2011 survey found that about a third of
Americans believe that natural disasters are
a sign from God, and that God punishes nations
for its’ citizens’ sins.
According to a recent survey, 11% of Americans
think the coronavirus pandemic is caused by
human sin.
Presumably, this idea is less popular in less
religious countries, like parts of Europe
and Australia.
But in some more religious countries, they’re
more popular – a survey in Pakistan found
that almost half believed that a drought was
God’s punishment.
This idea of divine punishment comes up whenever
there’s a big disaster – after Hurricane
Katrina, the Haiti earthquake, Indian Ocean
disaster, the Kashmir quake, and the disaster
in Japan.
In 2011, Japan was hit with a huge tsunami
that killed thousands of people, wiped away
entire towns, and caused a nuclear meltdown.
The Prime Minister of Japan urged for calm,
the Emperor spoke of hope and compassion.
But the governor of Tokyo said the disaster
was a punishment for the greed of the Japanese
people.
He used the word tenbatsu, meaning divine
punishment.
He was widely criticised for this statement,
but the next month, he was re-elected as governor.
So disaster as divine punishment is a persistent
and powerful idea.
What’s the history of this idea, how has
it changed, and how do we understand disaster
today?
For thousands of years, all over the world,
many cultures saw disasters as God’s punishment.
In ancient China, rulers were believed to
have a mandate from heaven.
Disasters were heaven’s punishment or warning,
meaning the ruler could lose their throne
because they’ve failed or been sinful.
According to legend, in the reign of King
Tang, there were terrible droughts.
So Tang asked if too much luxury or corruption
or- women caused the disaster.
He offered himself as a sacrifice in repentance,
but the heavens showed mercy, and the rains
came.
In Vanuatu, volcanic eruptions were believed
to come from demons or spirits, punishing
people for breaking cultural rules.
In Islamic scripture, disasters are often
signs of the apocalypse, or divine punishments.
There’s a story in the Quran about a prophet
who gives a town a miraculous camel.
The townspeople hurt the camel, so Allah destroys
the town with an earthquake.
In northern Europe, floods and frosts were
seen as God’s punishment.
There’s a German legend of a town called
Rungholt – the townspeople were immoral,
and the priest got drunk, so God swept the
town into the sea in a storm.
Some people call Rungholt 'the Atlantis of
the North Sea’.
In Mesoamerica, people believed that droughts
and plagues were divine punishments, so they
offered human sacrifice – the Aztecs sent
victims to the gods to plead mercy for our
sins.
According to a Mayan manuscript, one sacrifice
victim “took upon herself the guilt of the
locusts” that destroyed their crops, before
her heart was cut out.
In the Bible, God sends lots of disasters
as punishments.
He destroys the sinful cities of Sodom and
Gomorrah with a rain of burning sulphur.
God sends Ten Plagues to Egypt – turning
the river Nile to blood, sending locusts and
frogs, and a storm of hail and fire.
And there’s the story of the flood, where
God wipes out humanity for our wickedness.
The Biblical flood story is predated by similar
Mesopotamian flood myths, like in the Epic
of Gilgamesh.
The ancient Greeks had the flood myth of Deucalion,
where Zeus sends a flood to wipe out a corrupt
humanity.
So for a very long time, all over the world,
many people saw disaster as God’s punishment
– [almost like it’s the default belief
for humanity].
And it’s easy to imagine why.
When something terrible happens, we want to
understand why it happened.
We want to believe that there’s meaning
to our suffering.
Divine punishment gives a reason for disaster,
and can gives us a feeling of control.
Like yes, this disaster is terrible, but we
can avoid future disasters by repenting, or
making sacrifice, or blaming the gays.
And shit, like when the earth shakes or the
seas crash onto land, it sure seems like the
big man’s pissed.
For thousands of years, religious explanations
were the best explanations we had.
But things changed.
The Enlightenment was a time in 18th century
Europe that sparked new ideas in science and
philosophy.
People like Voltaire, Descartes, Isaac Newton,
challenged the old ideas of the church and
state.
One of these old ideas was philosophical optimism
– the belief that the world that exists
is the best possible world, and everything
that happens is just and necessary in God’s
plan – Alexander Pope said “whatever is,
is right”.
But this belief was shaken in the Lisbon earthquake
of 1755.
At the time, Lisbon was one of the biggest,
richest and most famous cities in Europe.
But on the morning of a religious holiday,
when the churches were packed with worshippers,
Lisbon was hit by a huge earthquake and tsunami.
Churches came crashing down upon the worshippers,
and the harbour was washed away.
Fissures tore the city apart, and fires burned
for days.
Tens of thousands of people were killed, and
almost all of the city was destroyed – one
of the only parts that survived were the brothels
in the red light district.
The priests declared that the quake was God’s
judgement – in this painting, this angel
with a fiery sword symbolises divine retribution.
A prominent priest in Lisbon wrote “what
a great harvest of sinful souls such disasters
send to Hell!”, and urged people to repent.
[Much like various religious leaders and Hulk
Hogan are saying now]
But Enlightenment thinkers questioned the
Church.
They asked awkward questions, like, why would
God destroy the royal palace, but leave the
brothels standing?
What sin was God punishing that was worth
killing thousands of people – when Lisbon
was a devout city celebrating a religious
holiday?
Enlightenment thinkers passionately debated
how to fit this disaster with their faith.
Voltaire wrote a poem about the quake, attacking
the ideas of optimism and divine punishment.
He asked “What crime, what sin, had those
young hearts conceived That lie, bleeding
and torn, on mother's breast?
Did fallen Lisbon deeper drink of vice Than
London, Paris, or … Madrid?”.
Does “this hellish gulf in Portugal” really
make the world better?
Couldn’t God have just, fucken, not made
volcanoes and quakes and shit?
Another Enlightenment thinker, called Rousseau,
replied to Voltaire.
He tried to defend the idea of optimism, but
also said the disaster was partly humanity’s
fault, because Lisbon’s buildings were too
tall, and too close together, and that made
the earthquake dangerous.
The Prime Minister of Lisbon rebuilt the city
with some of the world’s first earthquake-resistant
buildings, and he sent a questionnaire about
the quake all over Portugal, which was one
of the first ever systematic studies of the
effects of a disaster.
Immanuel Kant tried to explain the quake with
science, theorising that it was caused by
underground gases and minerals.
The Lisbon quake dramatically changed how
people think about disaster.
New ideas in seismology, disaster management,
urban planning, spread across Europe and the
world.
And they worked.
Today, in Japan, two hundred and fifty years
later, 11,000 kilometres from Lisbon, the
city of Tokyo has mastered earthquake mitigation.
There’s training and drills and instructions,
there are earthquake simulation machines to
train schoolkids.
Earthquake-resistant technology and regulations
make buildings safer, there’s a warning
system to send alerts.
Modern technology and governance can make
disasters much less dangerous and scary.
Instead of terrifying inexplicable calamities,
they can be natural phenomena that we can
manage and control.
Which means sometimes, we don’t need the
religious perspective.
Psychology research shows that we’re more
likely to believe in God, and to see meaning
in randomness when we’re feeling anxious,
and like we’re not in control.
So when disaster is managed and controlled,
we might not need religious explanations like
divine punishment.
Today, when things do go wrong, we tend not
to blame God or sin – we blame the government.
According to surveys, most Americans blame
local or foreign governments for the coronavirus.
Most Americans disapprove of the government’s
response to the pandemic.
There are also protests against government
lockdown measures.
There’s criticism of bodies like the World
Health Organisation, the UN and EU.
So when disaster strikes, instead of turning
to God, the higher power we turn to is government.
Some people believe conspiracy theories.
According to surveys, more than a quarter
of Americans think Bill Gates wants to use
corona vaccines to track people.
12% of Australians think that 5G is spreading
the virus, and 39% think the virus was created
in a Chinese lab.
So instead of believing that the disaster
is God’s plan, people believe it’s China’s
plan or Bill Gates’ plan.
According to psychologists, people believe
in conspiracy theories for similar reasons
that people believe in religion.
It’s a coping strategy that helps you deal
with a stressful uncertain world.
Cause, it’s terrifying to see that the world’s
a mess, no one’s really in charge, and it’s
hard to tell who’s good and who’s bad.
So it’s actually reassuring to believe that
all the evil in the world comes from the Illuminati
or whoever, everything’s part of their evil
plan, but you are the heroic woke resistance,
and anyone who says otherwise is just part
of the conspiracy.
A conspiracy theory can make you part of a
fun cool group who believe the same thing
– just like a religion.
But in a religion, the higher power is God.
While in conspiracy theories, the ones in
control, who cause the disaster.. are humans.
In the last hundred years, some of the worst
disasters aren’t natural disasters like
earthquakes – they’re man-made – like
nuclear meltdowns, oil spills, industrial
accidents – and climate change.
Our emissions are warming the Earth, melting
the Arctic, bleaching the reefs, worsening
extreme weather events and fires.
Whenever there’s a hurricane or heat wave
now, instead of blaming God or sin, people
attribute it to man-made climate change.
Poverty and famine is increasingly seen as
a “man-made” problem, caused by human
conflict and mismanagement.
War, terrorism, nuclear weapons – as human
power increases, so does our capacity for
destruction and disaster.
So we increasingly fear not apocalypse from
God, but apocalypse from ourselves.
In ancient mythology, apocalypse comes from
the gods – the Norse Ragnarök, the Biblical
Armageddon, the Epic of Gilgamesh.
And these kinds of stories are still popular
today – like superhero movies about godlike
beings fighting against magical apocalypse.
But in many modern myths, apocalypse is caused
by humans and human technology.
Man-made robots in Terminator and The Matrix,
man-made climate change in The Day After Tomorrow,
nuclear war in Fallout – in pop culture,
there’s this fear that we will destroy ourselves.
A great symbol of this is the zombie apocalypse.
The zombie apocalypse isn’t always caused
by humans.
But it’s a disaster made of humans.
A zombie horde looks a lot like the apocalyptic
floods of myth – a vast, terrifying, unstoppable,
all-consuming force [Halo zombies are called
The Flood].
But the biblical flood, from God, is made
of water, a natural force – while the zombie
horde is made of people.
If you watch some of the original zombie movies,
like Dawn of the Dead [1978], it's not just
about spooky bitey walking dead men.
It's about the failure of human institutions
like government and media.
It's about mindless consumer culture, greed
and tribalism, inequality and division, all
the evil that’s brought out by a crisis.
You can see zombies as an embodiment of all
the worst parts of human nature, the evil
that we fear we’ll find in ourselves when
disaster strikes.
The word apocalypse means revelation.
And we hope that disaster will reveal the
good in us.
But we fear it will reveal the worst– that
we can’t blame God or sin or 5G.
That there is no plan, punishment or conspiracy.
We fear that the disaster is us.
Disaster experts say that on its own, an earthquake
or tsunami or virus is not a disaster.
Cause these things only do damage if we leave
ourselves vulnerable to them, by failing to
properly prepare, and respond.
It's been 250 years since Lisbon.
We know that earthquakes and tsunamis and
viruses happen, we have the science and research
and resources.
Experts have warned us for decades to prepare
for a pandemic, urging for evidence-based
policy and public health measures, prevention
and precautions.
It’s not sexy.
It wouldn’t make a good movie, there is
no good versus evil.
There’s no lone hero like Noah [or Ziusudra]
or Deucalion or Brad Pitt to save us from
apocalypse – our myths mislead us.
Sometimes saving millions of lives doesn’t
require individual heroism, repentance or
sacrifice.
It requires careful planning, cooperation,
organisation, rationality, compassion – on
a local, political and international level.
That’s what separates us from the zombies.
Maybe the deadliest and most contagious viruses
are the myths we tell ourselves about apocalypse.
Stories and ideas define our history.
The ancients built empires on religion and
myth [on mandates from heaven].
The Enlightenment spread science, reason and
philosophy.
Now, we’ve got..
Kanye, Marvel, Trump, and whoever the fuck
started the 5G stuff.
Every day, mutant strains of information go
viral online, they infect our brains and change
us, rallying us into factions and mass movements,
shifting world economies and polities.
Every choice we make is based on what we think
we know.
So what we believe might be the difference
between Enlightenment and apocalypse.
After the disaster in Japan, Sato Hiroo wrote
that “Today, when the extinction of humanity
is increasingly becoming [possible], we are
all individually required as bearers of the
… future to make the tough choice of which
path to follow”. “we are facing a historical
turning point”, and we need to “think
hard about which direction to take”.
Thanks for watching.
If you want more videos like this, please
let us know in the comments, and consider
supporting on Patreon.
This video took a lot of research and work,
and it’s not sponsored, so we’re relying
on your support.
For a few bucks a month, you can get videos
early, and you can vote on our next Song of
Ice and Fire video topic.
Sign up at the link below.
Thanks to Patrons Alexandra Eliades, Andreas
Bardét, Brittany Ahern, Braydon Lee Hall,
Hoi Lan Tam, and PandaFire.
Cheers.